angry frustrated and helpless sri
lankans have had to queue up for most
essentials in recent weeks today they
were told there's no more petrol left
i came at eight o'clock this morning but
when i got close they said the petrol
was gone i don't even have enough to go
home
it's the poorest people that are the
worst affected we can't cope
a massive tax cut the 2019 easter
bombings targeting hotels and churches
and the pandemic have sharply affected
government revenue
this together with unsustainable debt
mismanagement and corruption made it
difficult for sri lanka to face the
economic problems in recent months
foreign reserves have fallen to near
zero and the government can't pay for
basic essentials
this included fuel from a tanker
anchored off colombo port for the past
45 days
the government owes 735 million dollars
on earlier fuel supplies
petrol
don't queue up for petrol because we are
working with very limited stocks which
are being allocated to essential
services like ambulances it will be
saturday or sunday before supplies are
available
sri lanka is facing its worst economic
crisis since independence in 1948.
shortages have brought ordinary sri
lankans to the streets demanding the
president gotabe rajapaksa's resignation
he says he won't resign and has
appointed a new prime minister ranil
vikramasingha voted out of parliament at
the last election he has a lot to prove
you and i will have to deal with the
most difficult times in our lives over
the next few months everyone will have
to face this with commitment
after months of stalling sri lanka has
opened talks with the international
monetary fund seeking a bailout but that
will take at least three or four months
to yield any relief
credit lines emergency loans and aid
have helped the government limp along in
recent weeks but observers say the
sooner there is political stability the
sooner the economy can begin its long
road to recovery
fernandez al jazeera colombo